on est venu manifester parce que on est
pour la France on est pour la République
et on est contre la réforme contre la
réforme
la France
le gars
[Musique]
et Toutatice le retour apparemment vous
êtes française et ça fait plaisir
alors ces images alors on va revenir
là-dessus parce que dans les médias
elles ont été reprises ces images et le
chroniqueur Nicolas fresco qui est dans
quotidien a réalisé une chronique qui a
été jugée sexiste il a lancé une
chronique avec une vidéo de Paul SCA
dans laquelle elle annonce qu'elle est
avec quel est son ami ils vont aller
manifester puis la présenter les deux
jeunes femmes en indiquant qu'elles
étaient connus pour avoir été recalés en
raison de leur décolleté plus profond
que le trou de la Sécu
voilà donc alors ça fait énormément
parler vous êtes influenceuse et c'est
vrai que là vous faites énormément
parler depuis ce week-end pourquoi vous
avez voulu manifester vous allez
manifester en fait on a voulu manifester
parce qu'on est contre la réforme et
c'est vrai qu'on est influenceuses qu'on
est forcément débile donc on peut pas
être engagé et d'ailleurs comme l'a dit
dès le début
c'est juste qu'il a pas entendu
et je voulais dire comme l'a dit Rokhaya
Diallo
que on a un décolleté plongeant qu'on
peut pas avoir une conscience politique
exactement d'ailleurs Marseille
elle est où là
vas-y alors et donc et moi alors donc
c'est quoi ça vous a pénible un petit
peu que tout le monde dise ouais on
comprend pas pourquoi le manifeste et
puis là il est fort contre notre
physique sur notre
façon mais en fait ça vous fait pas
changer du tout moi c'est ça que j'aime
c'est à dire que vous continuez dans le
dans les gens bah oui voilà donc c'est
c'est vrai que voilà vous vous continuez
dans votre délire vous continuez dans
votre truc et vous vous restez vous-même
vous vous comprenez les critiques ou pas
du tout non pas du tout
sur sa façon de s'habiller ou si le
vestimentaire c'est ses réseaux sociaux
on devrait apprendre à connaître la
personne pour de vrai
parce que je vais pas me permettre de
faire est-ce que vous pouvez remettre
votre micro droit merci dans votre micro
je vais le faire
mais non parce que vraiment vous
entendez mal euh Toutatice non mais qui
sont lourds sans régler mais vraiment
quelle lourdeur pourquoi ce slogan c'est
vous c'est une banane et qu'on écoute la
réforme les femmes contre la réforme
en fait on s'est dans notre personnage
on va pas manifester hyper sérieux mais
pas politicienne donc justement il y a
des gens qui voulaient qu'on manifeste
autrement et qui pensait qu'on était là
justement pour le bug parce qu'on
rigolait parce qu'on qu'on dansait etc
mais c'est notre manière de manifester
il y a plusieurs manières de manifester
pour moi c'est vraiment un faux débat
c'est une fausse polémique vous avez le
droit de le faire tout le monde a le
droit de manifester les mecs tout le
monde a le droit de donner son nez c'est
pas parce qu'on a un décolleté qu'on a
pas un avis sur ce qui se passe en
France ou sur la retraite ou sur ou
autre c'est c'est franchement ça c'est
c'est divan mais c'est c'est c'est pour
moi alors c'est c'est nul à chier moi je
fais des vannes j'ai envie de mettre des
tartes quand je vois des vannes comme ça
je vous le dis après on va dire que je
vais je vais je les mettrai pas parce
que sinon je vais prendre des amandes
mais ça me rend fou moi les des trucs
comme ça les donneurs de leçons et les
mecs qui qui
c'est insupportable et je trouve
vraiment que ça c'est pour moi c'est
sexiste au plus haut point franchement
c'est voilà et d'ailleurs
du coup la chronique du quotidien on l'a
trouvé donc hyper sexy de misogyne et je
vais d'ailleurs dire Guillaume canton tu
aurais dû postuler pour aller au
quotidien parce que je pense que tu
aurais pas savoir quoi
si nous le prennent on leur laisse hein
je pense que ce qui vous intéresse c'est
plus les caméras que le combat non mais
c'est vrai je pense que vous y allez
pour faire des Tik Tok c'était une manif
contre la réforme des retraites ça
aurait été une manif contre les
trottinettes vous y seriez allé aussi
c'est la même chose si
on est obligé de filmer c'est pareil je
suis désolé moi je vois des milliers des
millions de manifestants dans toute la
France ils ont des pancartes avec des
messages pas des perches à selfies et au
lieu de vous demander quand est-ce que
vous allez partir à la retraite
demandez-vous quand est-ce que vous
allez commencer un vrai boulot plutôt
c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
vous avez le droit de mettre les tenues
vous voulez je pense juste que vous
faites ça encore une fois pour faire des
Tic-Toc pour faire du buzz pour créer
une polémique pour répondre à la
polémique et pour gagner des abonnés etc
je veux juste ça moi
ils le font pas il y a un problème ils
le font il y a un problème sérieux on a
préféré faire plus que une story sur
fond noir c'est tout est-ce que vous
pensez que vous êtes concerné est-ce que
vous pensez que vous travaillez on n'est
pas concerné justement et déjà
concerné ou pas concerné elle fermait
parce qu'il se passe dans leur pays
comme tout le monde voilà ça se trouve
dans 10 ans je vais te caissière on sait
pas ce serait très bien bah oui
au-delà de ça il y a plein de jeunes qui
manifestent voilà qui qui sont concernés
qui sont pas concernés mais voilà elles
sont concernées par ce qui se passe dans
leur pays à mon avis oui c'est honteux
ce que dit Guillaume il est face à deux
figures iconiques de la culture
française
[Rires]
à mon avis
il vous kiffe bien
non mais c'est vrai bravo il a envie de
de hisser son drapeau lui aussi
[Rires]
je les aime beaucoup mais elles ont tout
à fait le droit cher Guillaume de
manifester et on dit souvent les jeunes
ne sont pas mobilisés qu'elles soient
pour ou contre elles expriment leurs
points de vue qu'elles soient concernées
parce qu'il se passe en France je trouve
ça admirable je vois pas pourquoi tu les
fustiges comme ça à l'enversion on a
bien compris un accès premium sur
omnifan mais c'est pas non mais en vrai
c'est pas le fait qu'elle n'ait pas le
droit de manifester c'est que je ne
crois pas en leur sincère c'est tout
c'est je ne crois pas votre sincérité
vous auriez aussi pu manifester sans
vous filmer sans vous mettre en scène
c'est tout et le but influenceur c'est
quoi l'influencer d'influencer autant
c'est qui
nous suivent on a plein de gens il y en
a plein qui nous dit merci maintenant on
sait plus en forme à la réforme on va
plus manifester etc c'est ça le but en
fait
et on ne fait que reprocher aux
influenceurs d'être déconnecté d'aller à
Dubaï et ne pas s'intéresser à la Ruby
républicaine là elles s'engage alors
niveau avec humour avec un peu d'auteur
dérision je suis désolé il y a en plus
leur slogan il est il est passé mal que
ça lorsque vous êtes allés dans la rue
allez voir les slogans franchement il y
en a qui sont un peu moins avancés
j'imagine et surtout que c'est la
meilleure preuve d'intelligence
il reviendra certainement dans des
prochains jours oui après Guillaume il y
a pas un certificat de validation pour
pour participer à une manifestation on
va pas dire toi tu as un décolleté tu es
pas bon toi tu instruction
d'accord et ça fait effectivement du
bien parce qu'ils sont tout le temps du
côté des donneurs de leçons du bon goût
des bons opinions du bon côté de tu as
de la route j'ai vu qu'il y a un mec qui
a pas beaucoup
cette semaine et en même temps si vous
permettez moi je trouve c'est bien
d'avoir un peu d'autodérision aussi et
la prochaine fois elle est manifester
pour les violences faites aux femmes et
les féminicides je pense que ce sera
plus important que la retraite parce que
quand on est jeune je trouve que c'est
un peu décalé voilà
le silence de Daniel et aussi à des
formes et qui sont pas au même endroit
j'ai tendance à être plutôt Tim
j'entends vous avez le droit de
manifester vous avez le droit d'avoir
des opinions maintenant tout ça vous
arrange bien vous êtes très maligne et
j'ai trouvé en revanche votre message
très très bien Paul c'était plein de
d'autodérision du tout du coup mais on
peut pas se plaindre quand on manifeste
quand on est habillé comme vous qui
suis désolée il faut être ça
elle va pas s'habiller
parce que ils ont pas le droit d'avoir
des idées
complètement
je vais te dire ce que je suis une vie
je veux dire la vérité en plus les
tenues là ça va ça passe vraiment basse
non mais vraiment là ça passe
désolé puis ça vous arrange bien
quotidien vous répondez
si vous aviez pas marché donc voilà ça
fait des fautes c'est très bien ils ont
pas demandé de se faire lâcher
en même temps
en quoi ça les arrange plus que les
artistes et 300 artistes qui ont signé
l'appétition alors eux ils ont la carte
ils ont eu ça
et elles sont pas suffisamment et donc
du coup il y a quotidien qui se met un
doigt un doigt dans la bouche pour vomir
enfin franchement excuse-moi c'est
dégueulasse non mais moi je suis
d'accord avec Géraldine ce qu'elle vient
de dire je souscris à tout ce qu'elle
vient de dire je trouve que
effectivement il faudrait avoir une
carte de la bonne manifestation la bonne
manifestante celle qui a le droit de
d'aller sur la place publique pour dire
qu'elle est pas d'accord ou qu'elle est
d'accord par ailleurs je trouve que le
billet moi je suis tout à fait pour la
dérision le second oignon je pense que
ces jeunes filles dans son pas
dépourvues en revanche elles ont été
blessées parce qu'il y avait une forme
de paternalisme voire de misogynie dans
le billet et donc c'est pour ça donc peu
importe qu'elle prête le flanc à ça ou
pas c'est à nous de ne pas y aller c'est
c'est à ceux qui font les de l'humour de
ne pas de ne pas aller sur ce terrain là
peu importe elles vont faire elles vont
manifester avec les armes qu'elles ont
avec les slogans qu'elles ont envie de
faire et on n'a pas nous après derrière
à les juger ou pas juger donc après on
va faire on va on va passer en défiler
tous les gens qui manifestent et on va
dire bah lui alors lui on va se [__]
de sa gueule pour ça lui pour elle
poursuit non je suis désolé s'il y avait
eu cette chronique pour TPMP
mais là effectivement je trouve que
c'était pas très malin après voilà après
j'ai vu après
ce que je trouve de plus en plus agaçant
dans ce pays c'est qu'il y a ceux qui
sont autorisés à penser et ceux qui ne
sont pas autorisés c'est valable c'est
valable pour vous voilà c'est valable
pour chien qui se permet de faire de la
politique ou de faire des missions
politiques chacun de moi ce que disent
les les poulets bien sûr je veux le dire
dans la rue mais comprenez par là que
c'est vraiment il y a ceux qui ont le
droit de parler et ceux qui ont pas
droit de parler et ça c'est vraiment
insupportable et dans votre cas c'est un
faux procès effectivement si on avait
fait des remarques aussi sexistes dans
cette émission se révé défoncer et je
trouve que c'est très agaçant il y a
ceux qui font de la bonne pub à la
télévision quand on fait le café quand
on fait le café
un exploitant
on les attaque on leur dit qu'elles sont
pas concernés mais comme elles l'ont dit
tout à l'heure bah elles ont une famille
elles ont des grands-parents elles ont
une mère enfin c'est pas parce qu'on
n'est pas concerné à l'instant T et
comme m'a dit Paul SCA ça se trouve dans
dans 2 ans dans 5 ans elle sera
caissière bah oui on n'en sait rien et
du coup bah là elle sera concernée donc
c'est pas parce qu'on n'est pas dans le
truc à l'instant T qu'on peut pas dans
les rues après je pense qu'elles sont
intelligentes belles Malines elles ont
beaucoup d'humour et elles savent
qu'elles sont et ce qu'elles veulent et
je pense pas sincèrement moi j'ai rien
contre vous mais je pense que vous
n'êtes plus à ça près de ce qu'on dit
sur vous pour que là ça vous blesse à ce
point-là et c'est quand même chouette
qu'on parle de vous parce que c'est
votre fond de commerce aussi et c'est
pas c'est pas pour vous je pense pas que
vous le ressentiez comme un drame étant
donné que malheureusement on parle
souvent de vous pour ces choses là et
vous assumez et tant mieux en fait c'est
juste surement à chaque fois de pas se
faire prendre au sérieux en fait et puis
mais vous ne faites pas mon anniversaire
non plus il faut accepter aussi un peu
d'humour
que on prenne notre défense pour une
fois
des journalistes
pour vous là quand même il y a des
positif
sinon ça va
j'aimerais dire quelque chose j'aimerais
que tous les par exemple députés qui ont
voté pour
la raison ouvrier ou d'une personne dans
le milieu médical au moins pour une
semaine et je pense qu'ils vont changer
d'avis très vite